the way that they want to identify and  respect the way that they want to  present themselves to the world I would  like to identify I do identify actually  as the correct person on this issue of  abortion I identify as being correct and  more correct than you on this issue and  I would just ask that you accept and  affirm my uh identity do you well you  are not a medical professional an  abortion and pregnancy  that's not your identity that is my I  promise you that's my identity I promise  you that's very different from your  sexual and gender identity how so what  what I'm talking here involves the mind  I mean don't you think I'm not just  talking about my gonads or something  like that I'm talking about I'm not just  talking about my sexual appetites or  desires I'm talking about my my mind my  capacity for reason my judgment here and  so you're saying you don't respect that  identity but you do respect the identity  of a man who believes himself to be a  woman